tractor beams are no longer just a  figment of science fiction scientists  are now using sound to levitate and move  small objects using a block of special  loudspeakers ultrasonic waves come  together to form an invisible sonic  support system called an interference  pattern the ultrasonic waves can  levitate and move the beads sideways up  and down or it can rotate it as the  speakers emit variations of sound waves  called phases the interference patterns  change that allows the bead to move in  different directions in the past  levitation only worked if the speaker's  surrounded the object but in this setup  the speakers are only on one side  scientists think this will facilitate  some pretty innovative applications in  the future drug delivery microsurgery or  even artificial gravity  you  you  you